[Musique]
allez aussi doit-on one man show et moi
sommes en dessous et on est très
contents que je sois îles hawaï ont dit
one woman show bien sûr puisque vous
êtes une femme anne et c'est important
d'avoir l'oeil sur ces manchots
seulement shoah très bien oui
[Musique]
juste un mot vous commencez à connaître
beaucoup de people iam en moi aussi vous
commencez à tous un peu dans vos amitiés
à vous tromper parfois surgir et bien
fabien des allemands je vous adore
[Musique]
vous les connaissez pas bien vous la
connaissiez est une actrice comme rhodia
one man one woman show oui et alma
s'appelle comment son one woman show et
des reines bien qu'on dise femmes en
scène seul en scène
beaucoup va pas bien loin ouais bah on a
eu un petit truc en fin mai soit un truc
dans les regards des regards bon
d'accord vous pensez que vous
non je la regardais en tout cas mal à
vous poser quand fabienne vous pour être
son style fait éclater réponse s'il a le
courage de l'avouer je pense fabienne on
va attendre la fin d'année commenté dire
quoi mais non mais dis le tunnel mais
n'ont c'est pas votre délire mais je ne
suis pas là dedans mais dans quoi
[Rires]
oui à autrement autrement si vous deviez
célibataire mais non mais je veux pas
mais n'ont jamais désespéré
j'aime beaucoup cette personne mais
monsieur vous avez la possibilité d'être
désinfecté
mais jean michel sapanet sa saison non
mais
on parlera après tout ça c'est très
gênant là c'est donc avec fabienne
puisque c'est pas la première fois que
vous venez sur notre plateau et si vous
revenez si souvent c'est parce que vous
êtes ce qu'on dit dans le jardinet et
parce que vous êtes une bonne cliente 1
vous avez toujours le bon mot la bonne
réponse qui va bien bonne cliente
enfin chez nous du moins parce que quand
vous donner des interviews à la provence
c'est pas là même où la glycémie quand
on est journaliste peut-on avoir la
sensation d'être seul sur son plateau
alors qu'on est deux
la réponse est oui aussi infatigable
militant de réflexion les gg
j'ai répondu après oui mais c'est vrai
qu'elles sont dues ces questions qu'il
était trop fatigué pour faire une
interview moi si j'étais en forme
d'ailleurs je suis crevé je n'ai
[Musique]